today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
we do have major breaking news president
donald trump has announced that he has
tested
positive for coronavirus and there are
so many layers to discuss i i hope to
discuss
all of them let's go through it in
sequence first what has been alleged
what do we believe that we know about
the situation well
uh late last night early this morning
close to one am eastern time donald
get through this together news of this
came after it was announced
that a close uh um staffer to donald
trump hope hicks had tested positive now
already just based on the facts with no
speculation
we know that irresponsible behavior took
place here
we've since learned that there was
actually a concern about hope hicks
early on thursday and that donald trump
knowing he had been exposed still went
to a fundraiser did not wear a mask and
we don't know how many more people were
exposed
as a result of donald trump's behavior
after being in contact with hope hicks
not surprising he's not taking it
seriously from the beginning second
a ton of people don't believe this and i
am not
uh asserting any conspiracy
but when i woke up this morning the
number of people who had emailed me
saying
this is a ruse to get out of the debates
trump doesn't really have coronavirus
this is a staged plan to in 10 days or
12 days for trump to come out and say
i beat it i told you it's no big deal
to make them seem strong to his
followers
maybe to say i beat it with hydroxy or i
beat it with remdesseviere we have such
great treasure
treatments or plasma or plasma or
whatever right
the counter to that would be yeah i mean
i get it trump lies all the time and he
might be lying about everything
including this
wouldn't just getting it make him look
weak to some of his supporters it seems
like an
you know potentially risky gambit to lie
about having it to then lie about
beating it but there is
widespread uh concern about this
the the the sort of uh less wacky
idea that a lot of people are emailing
me about
is well isn't it possible that this is
an escape pod for donald trump
because he sees the writing on the wall
after that first debate
the odds of biden winning have gone up
the odds of biden winning
of trump winning have gone down and
donald trump
we knew all along that if he lost he was
going to say i got screwed by
coronavirus otherwise i would have won
everything was great best economy
black people were working all the stuff
he says hispanic low unemployment
all of this stuff uh that now seeing the
writing on the wall
he is potentially using this to simply
get out
uh and or even to throw the election he
doesn't necessarily
i mean if he were to get very sick he
wouldn't even necessarily have to say
i'm no longer
running but you would imagine that there
are some people who would say i can't
vote for a guy who's so sick we need a
healthy president
i i just i understand why people are
suspicious because this is an
administration
that has lied constantly about
everything
but as of right now um at at least
plausibly donald trump has coronavirus
is experiencing mild
cold like symptoms and
it is quarantining all future
immediately future events have been
canceled of course the second debate is
scheduled for about 12 days from today
it's
not this coming thursday in other words
not six days from today
but the following thursday i guess that
makes that 13 days from today
it would be very borderline given
how long one can remain infectious it
would be very borderline to be able to
be at an in-person debate
13 days from today if you just tested
positive yesterday so no announcement
has been made as of this moment
it's something we're going to be
following it's something that that we
are
going to be tracking here uh the
the sort of next layer to this is you
know
a lot of the a lot of the feelings
that have been bottled up for months uh
or not bottled up
but but sort of simmering there about
donald trump not taking this seriously
and so on they are coming out and there
are a lot of people who are saying what
i think are sort of horrible things
about they hope trump dies i'm getting
tweets and messages
i hope trump gets a really serious case
i hope he does i i think that
that happens to be both morally wrong
uh and also strategically wrong let me
take it one by one
first the moral part i don't wish death
or disease on anyone even bad people
i don't really believe in karma but it
just feels
wrong to me to hope for things like that
now i understand
trump has not taken the 211 212
000 american coronavirus deaths
seriously so why should we care about
one
we're not like them okay we're better
than them
we are not going to stoop to their level
so
donald trump deserves to lose and this
gets to the practical trump deserves to
lose and he deserves to be voted out
via a massive repudiation by the
american people
not by getting sick okay so i
i maintain uh and listen this is not the
hill i'm going to die on i understand
why some people are reacting in these
ways screw trump and all i get it
but uh uh if for for me i would take
no not only do i not take pleasure in
people getting sick and dying
fundamentally that seems that that is
antithetical to my beliefs
i wouldn't take pleasure in removing
trump because he gets sick or dies
i want him repudiated by the vote
plain and simple period uh full stop now
by the way uh just as a funny funny or
ironic or coincidental personal story
i've been having some uh
what i think are sort of allergic
symptoms lately
and my doctor said listen before we test
for allergies
because coronavirus is so weird get
yourself a coronavirus test so i
actually went yesterday after filming
the show and i got one and it really
wasn't too bad
uh they're using a much thinner swab now
and
you know whatever when i woke up this
morning anticipating
my coronavirus test results i saw trump
had tested positive for coronavirus and
again
it it trump's test and my test are
completely unrelated
but for some reason i had this vision of
announcing both
that trump had tested positive and that
i had tested positive i tested negative
uh got my results this morning within
minutes of hearing about donald trump's
positive test
completely unrelated but just a uh a
timing
issue has me announcing that today
hopefully my test was an accurate
negative
we wouldn't want a a false negative so
we're going to continue following this
no trump events scheduled for the
foreseeable future as a result of this
donald trump will be quarantining he has
coronavirus melania trump has
coronavirus
hope hicks has coronavirus and i would
not be surprised to see others test
positive
in the days to come last week i
mentioned to you that
in the 36 hours or so after the tragic
death of supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg
100 million dollars was donated to joe
biden and other democrats a real sign of
enthusiasm to put it
very very lightly well we now have
fundraising numbers from tuesday and joe
biden raised
10 million dollars during the three-hour
period
surrounding the first presidential
debate with donald trump
in the first hour alone joe biden raised
3.8 million dollars
this is a campaign fundraising record
for a single hour and then if you look
at the 9 p.m to midnight eastern bloc
10 million dollars raised 215 000
donations
including 60 000 new donors who had not
previously donated
and 100 000 people
signed up to volunteer for the campaign
now this is not a guarantee of anything
we don't yet have trump's fundraising
numbers to compare
for during the debate but this is very
good for joe biden and
i i feel like i don't even need to say
this now but i will
i hate how our elections are financed i
despise
the money system that we have but for
the next 35 days it's the system that we
have and the one that joe
biden has to use to win and seeing 10
million dollars raised in three hours is
just stunning
what seems to have to be motivating lots
of donations is people realize when they
were watching the debate
uh trump doesn't want more people to
vote
trump wants fewer people to vote there
was no way
to watch the debate and not pay
attention to the reality
that donald trump would prefer that you
not vote
particularly if you don't like him but
on balance donald trump has figured out
that all else being equal
he's better off if he suppresses the
vote and it was very transparent during
that debate
people didn't like it people saw it and
they saw
the completely undemocratic
authority authoritarian nature of donald
trump
who also doesn't want to accept the
election results
unless he wins and is preemptively
saying
if the results are anything other than
he won he will say that the results are
rigged
and this has motivated people to donate
we will see where it gets us
in just about a month but what what i
like hearing about this is
to put it lightly there are a lot of
ignorant
and uninformed people in this country
who
fall for anything and 60 million of them
fell for voting for trump in 2016.
60 million are likely going to fall for
it again what was
for me inspiring to see was that even
though donald trump didn't come out and
say
i don't want people to vote i want
people to stay home
he used sort of coded language people
saw through it
people watched it and they said i can
determine from what he is saying what he
really means and i don't like it
and i'm going to donate to joe biden so
incredible numbers for biden
i'll have the trump numbers for you when
they are out the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is
only about eight bucks a month and you
get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
all right welcome back to the show
everybody we're going to do calls today
but we're doing them a different way
because of all of the complaints about
the call quality on
the phone line we are going to for the
first time
try taking callers through discord which
is davidpakman.com
discord so let's just try it okay we're
going to go
first uh to rachel from arizona
rachel from arizona you're the first
caller on today
uh in terms of using the new discord
system
welcome can you hear me can we hear you
i can hear you can you hear me rachel
you're coming through
crystal clear how are you today
good good what's uh what's on your mind
well
well after that dumpster fire of a
debate last night
i mean i just
i don't think there was a clear winner
on either side
so i mean listen i i agree with you that
it was a mess and
trump's strategy was to make debate
impossible i do
think that on balance like it's hard for
me to say because i'm in this like i'm
not the target of this debate you know
i'm voting for biden and it's i'm very
clear on that
but i think the big picture is
biden looked stable and trump didn't and
i think that if we imagine
a casual political observer sure people
who want like an alpha
type that insults everybody they might
be drawn to trump but
i think it probably is better for biden
how it went
right i agree with you on that 100
i mean compared to trump biden just
looked like
a saint right compared to him just
you know his hot-headedness and and
it was it was definitely um not the norm
for a presidential debate
now let me ask you this rachel as
someone who follows politics
do you based on how that debate went do
you feel any need to watch future
debates or are you sort of like good for
the rest of this election
um i just want to watch it for the pure
uh you know
what's the word i'm like the
entertainment values like a train yeah
the entertainment it's like a train
wreck you just can't look away
yeah yeah yeah yeah see i think that
it's hard for us to analyze it because
i'm trying to think of people who are
watching it to try to figure out who to
vote for how are they seeing it and my
we'll have to see in the coming days how
the polling shifts but my instinct is it
did more more damage for trump than it
did for biden
right and i am i'm originally from ohio
and so i have a lot of people on my
facebook and instagram from ohio
yeah and i was kind of interested to see
their take on it because a lot of them
are for trump
right and um you know they're just
making excuses for him oh
you know he he got the hardest questions
and oh that's interesting because so
because one reaction would be to insist
that trump did great and he won
but what you're seeing is people aren't
saying
trump did great and he won but they're
excusing the fact that he imploded by
saying he was
he got the hard questions and whatnot
correct that's interesting
that's different i mean i think that
signals it was worse for trump
because they're not even able to just
claim he won they're having to make
excuses for the performance that
actually is interesting
right well i mean that's all they've
done for the past four years isn't it
make excuses for him very true very true
rachel thank you for the call where in
arizona are you
i am in tempe tempe okay i've never been
there i've been to tucson i've been to
phoenix i've been to some wineries down
uh closer to the i think sonora near the
mexican border
beautiful beautiful place yes it's very
gorgeous
it's especially right now it's like just
a little above 100 still and it's just
perfect weather
but it's a dry heat so it's fine yes yes
that's what they all say
all right thank you so much for having
me on appreciate
thanks rachel great to hear from rachel
let's go
next to uh we're gonna go to
sam from houston sam from houston is
joining us
uh sam i would say what's your name and
where are you calling from but i already
have that information
and you're going to have to unmute
yourself sam if you want to chat
which which we want we want you to
unmute um but you do have to unmute
yourself
sam from houston you've got to unmute
you are muted there you go sam
hey david how are you doing good how are
you i'm doing
i feel like i ptsd after that debate
right
uh so i guess i wanted to get your take
on um
the biggest i way that the left will
look at the debate for biden
yesterday and mostly from the standpoint
i guess of
whoever is still undecided at this point
how do you view
their reaction their uh
viewpoint so you're saying specifically
left-wing
undecideds people who are politically
left but they're not sure about voting
biden yet
right right i i mean listen this is so
speculative and we really have to wait
for the polling
but my instinct is that there will be
some on the left and they're very loud
on twitter and on reddit there will be
some on the left who will say
biden stumbled and bumbled and we can't
have this guy
in office but then they're gonna vote
the guy in
who talked about biden's son's cocaine
problem
and said he needs that the proud boys to
stand by
for after the election like that's how
you that's who you're going to go with
so
i think we shouldn't uh be be
tricked into thinking that a lot of the
left is reacting to biden by saying wow
now i'm voting
trump because of that debate i think
that for the left
remember most undecideds aren't
left-wing undecideds tend to be center
and center-right who don't pay too much
attention but
for left-wing undecideds i think biden
was stable and trump was a petulant
child and it probably helps biden with
the left wing undecided
there's very few of them though
yeah i i think that that's the best way
to look at last night
because of the fact that it was just
screaming and is there anything that you
would advise the next
moderator for the next debate because
chris well listen
the modern moderator needs to be able to
control the microphones of the
candidates both candidates would have to
agree to it and it's not going to happen
so what i think the next best thing can
be
is the moderate this could make the
debate last twice as long but the
moderator should enforce
that if trump interrupts biden biden's
time
stops and it gets taken away from trump
so for example
and it's very hard to do if biden's
supposed to get two minutes and trump
talks for 30 of it
biden gets another 30 and that 30 counts
against trump's next time slot
they're not going to allow it they're
not going to do it it's logistically
difficult but what else can you do
oh i would i would love that i think
that that would be the best thing to be
able to cut one of the both of their
mics off because it was bad
but but again they both need to agree to
it and they're never going to
right well i'm excited until i'll watch
it watch the next week
yeah you're sort of breaking up you're
sort of breaking up sam but i i know
that you're saying the kamala
uh pence debate we'll be here for it i
think kamala is going to crush him
yeah thanks so much david appreciate it
all right sam
uh sam may have been exercising or using
power tools there so we're gonna let him
let him get back to it
uh let's go back to um
oh here i think this is a call from uh i
think this is a call from
israel let's go to peleg
from ashkelon peleg what's going on and
remember you have to unmute yourself
i've brought you in but you've got there
you are hey david how's it going good
how are you
um great to talk to you um watch your
live stream yesterday it was awesome
thank you so basically my question is
though i live in israel
and i've been hearing a lot of talk
about biden and his
uh policy towards israel um
so like from one end i can uh i can hear
stuff like oh his bds
is a radical and uh from another uh
side i can hear like uh oh he's uh good
for us uh
he's friendly to our lobbyists and stuff
like that so
i guess my question is um what's your
opinion about biden's policy towards
israel and uh
um yeah your general opinion on it well
it's not about my opinion it's what is
biden said so first you said you heard
that
some people said biden's for bds has
baid never studies for bds
i could not find that yeah he hasn't
said it so biden's not for bds
with with regard to the relationship
biden would be completely
unremarkable in his relationship to
israel it would be very similar to
barack obama
i mean certainly if benjamin netanyahu
is not a factor the relationship will be
improved and you might get a credible
opportunity for
for serious uh peace discussions but
there is going to be nothing remarkable
at all about it's sort of like trump
says biden will end the second amendment
now biden will try to get
some sensible reforms passed maybe
universal background checks and a few
other things
it will be very similar to what barack
obama tried to do trump says biden's
going to end the suburbs and you know
kind of this racial uh
dog whistling no he's not and there are
some on the right saying biden will be
terrible for israel or for american jews
or whatever
no he won't he will be completely
unremarkable
in in every way with his with regard to
israel israeli policy
great that's exactly what i think too
and i tried to explain that to people
great
like what's going on now in israel in
terms of masks so a lot of people i
follow
who live in israel they're out in cafes
they're at gyms not wearing masks what's
the deal yes that is a problem and we've
had like a lot of talk about it
and also like uh now right now there are
a lot of pr uh protests against uh
benjamin netanyahu yeah
every like i think saturday i might be
wrong about it uh
so a lot of people don't wear master and
a lot of criticism about that
from what i know right now we are on a
shutdown
it's gonna end like in about five days
so uh
uh right now it seems to be uh steady
and in terms of mass people generally
respect it and
yeah okay because i don't see anybody
wearing masks but they respect when it
when you're supposed to you're saying
people are wearing a mask
when i usually go out i see about
70 of people wear masks but
might be my memory that's not bad that's
not bad okay all right peleg i'm gonna
let you go sounds like you're juggling a
lot over there but i appreciate hearing
from you
let's go uh we really are taking a tour
of the world today i want to go next to
eric
from toronto uh our friendly neighbors
to the north eric you can go ahead
and unmute and i would love to hear
what's on your mind holy crap
well first i wasn't expecting to talk to
you but uh
hopefully you're doing well i enjoy your
content well listen eric when i woke up
this morning
i didn't expect to be talking to you
either so we're both in the same
situation
well after watching the debate last
night i was watching your live stream
oh my god just horrified yeah
i um
i i don't know if there's a winner to
this debate to be honest and it didn't
sway anyone either way
it's just it's just unfortunate like
people are brainwashed into believing
trump it's just
crazy and i can't imagine like
thinking that he's the choice to pick
for this election it's just oh my god
i tend to agree with you that the debate
so if you
if you follow somebody who predicts
elections
with a qualitative rubric like alan
lichtman
he doesn't think debates make any
difference at all and i i tend to agree
in terms of the math of it the the only
thing is
a very small margin in a few states
could flip the election so
while i don't think the debates will
move the polling significantly
i do recognize that you know if just one
percent of the population
in wisconsin found trump to be a
petulant child and biden to seem like an
adult
that one percent could actually swing
wisconsin you know you understand what
i'm saying
yeah i am and another thing i want to
bring up while i'm here is i i really do
hope that moderating gets better like i
remember what you were saying like
why aren't they cutting the mics well
they don't have the mechanism
the parties the parties would have to
agree to that to give the moderator that
power and of course trump
in particular never would uh yeah and
it's upsetting though i mean you can
just see how broken it all is i'm just
talking with my co-worker here i'm
working at the same time
it's just like we're both just talking
like how can they not mute the mics like
what kind of process is this if the
trump disputes
garble over yeah i mean like not that
biden was like anything to write home
about either like you said but
no like i said yesterday biden had four
to five strong answers in particular his
last answer he had about
three zingers and he had five or six
weak moments where he seemed uh unable
to kind of sequentially lay out a vision
and i think that those are the moments
that trump is going to fixate on
yeah every time biden stuttered i i my
heart sank a little bit but
you know what i think he at least didn't
faze plant right that's
that's the important thing and um yeah
you know i'm just happy to check in with
you that's all i really had to say um
also uh hello pat and uh you know thanks
for taking my call
all right thank you very much we're
gonna uh say goodbye to
eric from toronto and pat you can make a
note that
people have said hello and that's a
beautiful thing we're going to go to a
very brief
break if you're holding on don't go
anywhere because we're going right back
to the calls momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right welcome back to the program
we're taking calls today via discord for
the first time
and i have to tell you davidpakman.com
discord it really has
improved audio quality dramatically
we're continuing
our tour of the world next we are going
to go to mikko from
finland i love finland i had the
pleasure of being there
last year it was an amazing experience
mikko where in finland are you and
what's on your mind today
hi david it's uh uh
it's dark here and it's cold and uh on
my mind it is
that your country seems to be on the
words of civil war and
at the end of democracy yes very clear
your assessment from finland is accurate
thank you now
what do you think if things do get
violent and do get out of hand and fall
into anarchy
what good pointers could you give to
people to do and how to react and what
to do
if the anarchy breaks out i don't know
the answer to that
you know i i have friends on the left
who never considered getting firearms
before
who were never preppers who now uh have
firearms they are
very very scared about the possibility
for violence
i i don't know what to advise people to
do
uh my my hope is that
state national guards are not going to
allow
violence incited by donald trump to take
over states
i cannot imagine you know we have a
republican governor here in
massachusetts charlie baker
despite being a republican charlie baker
refused to send any national guard down
to the border when donald trump wanted
to use the national guard down there
my belief is if it really came to it and
i hope it doesn't that charlie baker is
going to use the state national guard
to protect against the violence that
donald trump may be
wanting to incite but i am as much in in
the dark
metaphorically miko as you were saying
finland is in the dark uh from the
standpoint of light because
i don't know what's going to happen okay
thank you that's very good answer uh
then
another word that i have found that is
very
descriptive of your country at the
moment is kakista
krasi kakistakis yes yes
which which i think that is uh
well means that the country is governed
by the least qualified
do you agree uh it's it's hard to find
people less qualified than trump yeah i
mean i was thinking
you know i think back to my college
professors earlier this week i
interviewed richard wolff okay richard
wolf is a socialist a lot of people
aren't socialists
richard wolff would have handled the
pandemic better than donald trump i
think back to i ran into a high school
english teacher over the weekend
my high school english teacher dropped
in to deal with coronavirus
would have handled it better than donald
trump merely by deferring to experts
it's hard to imagine short of someone
who is truly cognitively disabled
straight up disabled of people that
would be worse suited to be in charge
right now
you're absolutely correct i'm so
sorry that is come to this yeah
hope the next hope for the next one yeah
mikko listen what what part of uh
what part of finland are you in i'm
about one hour drive away from
helsinki downtown and it's a little bit
over one hour by car and
we're very southern part well i love
helsinki there's this uh are you
familiar with this
salmon soup that is very typical of
helsinki
yes i am salmon soup is actually very
typical of
all of finland what a what a dish what a
delightful dish i just had i must have
had that 10 times when i was in finland
absolutely delicious nice to hear
yeah uh all right mikko i appreciate you
calling in and i hope to be back in
finland before too long
okay we'll come all right there it is
mikko
what a friendly guy people are just so
friendly in uh
in finland let's go next to
um i want to go to i think we're going
to the uk
now with ian from southampton
ian uh welcome to the program what's on
your mind
uh so i have some uh tactics questions
regarding biden's performance last night
please
um i watched the whole thing it was
about
3am to 4am for me so i was a little bit
out of it
uh but i did notice that he actually
just
came out and said that trump was the
worst president of the united states yes
that was a great moment in my mind well
here's the thing
for me the way he delivered that and
actually the way he delivered a number
of the other
insults which i think are really just
adjectives in this case
yes um was in a way that
didn't necessarily seem to be serious it
didn't seem to be the denunciation it
should be it seems very
joe biden this is all you know it's kind
of funny what this trump guy is and who
he thinks he is
you know i don't totally disagree and by
the way i'm hearing all sorts of discord
tweets and beeps so if you can mute
those
that would be a beautiful thing how
would i do that that i don't know
that i don't know but um my what i was
going to say is
i actually liked the biden laughing
because
trump as a narcissist and trump is an
authoritarian
he wants people angry and afraid and
nothing communicates the opposite
then biden just laughing trump off as an
unserious person so i
i don't disagree with you with the micro
which is when biden said trump's the
worst president ever he didn't really do
it in the serious denunciation way we
might have liked to see
but it was part of just laughing the guy
off and i think trump really didn't like
that
yeah so this is kind of um my next point
is that
to me what that signaled is on some
level that
trump isn't necessarily a threat and
trump isn't serious
and he did have that big moment at the
end where he was talking he did the very
serious look to camera get out and vote
which i liked again
um but it's it seems that
the the sort of laughing laughing off at
that bit at least laughing for some of
it is fine and
some of the sillier stuff he said was
fine yeah but i feel that he
he missed the mark with some of the
insults and the denunciations
all right fair point and point well
taken ian i am going to let you go
because the the the beeps are just uh
they're really yeah
they're creating a problem for us but
it's a point taken and reasonable people
can
can certainly disagree uh we're going to
go
next to just to keep it going
in the united states i do want to let
our american friends get in on here
let's go to tyler from
austin texas the new home
of joe rogan tyler what is it like
having joe rogan in town
you know i hear a lot of complaints
about it but it doesn't really bother me
it is what it is you know very people
want to come here and contribute to the
economy
and i'm fine with it cool don't move out
yet
what's on my mind so my question
is about something i've been doing a
little bit of investigating into
is the opinions that a lot of
conservative media pundits have held
about trump in the past back in the 2016
election
right they said extremely disparaging
things about him
and they were in full recognition that
he was a racist even like an anti-semite
so on and so forth and what i'm really
concerned about is
following this election even if trump
loses
what is gonna stop um when are
conservatives gonna reflect
and realize that the candidate has gone
too far
that even though he has the effect that
they want on their base
getting up support that he is too out of
left field that he's too awful of a
person
when are they gonna have a moment of
reflection because i don't see that
happening right now i don't see
them realizing the situation that
they've gotten themselves into
well there is a lot of cognitive
dissonance that prevents people from
having that awakening and so
i think that only if donald trump
brutally loses i'm talking about
landslide loss
and republicans lose the senate i mean
if there's a real repudiation of
everything republicans are and stand for
at the senate and white house level
will you see some republicans say that
was
really disastrous that can never happen
again but otherwise
i think you'll see even if trump loses a
lot of republicans chalk it up to
coronavirus
a lot of republicans chalk it up to bad
timing um and i i would be shocked if
there's any kind of serious so
exis self-examination
a reckoning of sorts yeah i doubt it i
just don't think you're gonna see it
um because i'm worried about somebody
who's just as bad
as trump or even worse in the future
coming along
and being legitimized just like he has
and i can't see a reason why they
wouldn't do that since he has been a
really
reliable vehicle like i said and like
you've said before for ginning up that
support
and like rachel bittikoffer said for
activating his base
you're completely right you're
completely right if they go against him
then they cancel out that section of the
electorate and they have to figure out a
way to move
left which i can't see them doing that
no i think that in fact
um it it it would take some very
accurate politicking for several
election cycles
to get past the risk that very soon
a trump number two comes forward and
whether it's one of his kids or whether
it's someone else
yeah i don't know but we're gonna have
to work really hard to prevent that and
and step
removing uh trump with and replacing him
with biden is just the first step of
many
i've seen norman orensey and i don't
know if you know who that is the
political scientist he says that the
republicans need to lose three elections
in a row
in a landslide in order for them to have
this reckoning that we're talking about
that's my instinct
i think i think that he's right yeah
okay well thank you so much for the call
it kind of really caught me off guard
that i just got slid into the room i
appreciate it tyler tyler from austin
texas great to hear from you
uh we are going to go next to um
where are we going next let's go to our
friend
sasha from montreal one of my favorite
favorite
uh cities in the world i would even say
sasha from montreal you can uh go ahead
and yeah let me know what's on your mind
today
well i was kind of disappointed
yesterday to be fair
yeah um lonely
i was really disappointed like just the
interruption
i finally couldn't speak he couldn't
talk he couldn't
it was crazy yeah i just
i i shouldn't have watched it like i was
just i was really hyped for it
but sorry you were hyped or you were
high
hyped i all right i know some people who
were both but
yeah no i understand i mean are you do
you imagine you'll watch the next
debates
i mean probably you will okay nothing
better to do i guess
yeah all right anything else for me
sasha
um not really no
uh you ever go to st via tour bagel in
montreal
uh i don't think so oh i recommend it
i don't actually live there i live in
the the suburbs oh you're in the suburbs
i see
yeah all right sasha very good i
appreciate the phone call
okay all right there it is sasha from
montreal very good
understated phone call uh let's go back
across the pond to peter from
leeds in the united kingdom peter what's
going on with you
um oh hi david uh i've just got a couple
of questions
um to do with um first of all
i'd like to talk about the passing of
the internal market bill in the uk
and the fact that the uk has basically
said you know what
screw the rule of international law i've
just won i'm just wondering
what you think um like
what do you think things might end up
like
with the us because i think it was even
nancy pelosi or joe biden he basically
said that like
um you're in that you're in the back of
the queue
if you start flagrantly violating
international law
i've just been wondering first of all
about that
listen i've not seen this uh so i would
not be able to
intelligently comment on it i mean from
from a very general standpoint
i don't disagree with the notion that
you are putting yourself in a particular
group when you violate international law
the united states violates its fair
share of international law and it
becomes a question of
are you big enough or well connected
enough or powerful enough that you can
get away with it and not everybody can
uh the uk is probably in a position to
be able to get away with it
without knowing the details yeah i mean
it's it's largely to do with brexit i
mean
the thing is the uk negotiated it like
um i think it was a few months ago
yeah so i'm just kind of worried that
like
people aren't gonna take us seriously
and i suppose this kind of links into
what else we need to think about as kind
of
social democrats or whatever across the
world
yes um how do we deal with this kind of
thing
how do we deal with our kind of i
i don't know how to describe them kind
of neo-nationalist type leaders
like boris johnson donald trump but
further afield to jaya bolsonaro
well the first step is to remove them
and only then can you even really start
to have a conversation about how to deal
with the fact that
you know in the united states even if
you remove trump you still have 60
million trumpists that you have to
contend with and that's a conversation
that
i'm sort of tabling at least for the
next 36 days until we have the election
over with but that's a very important
question
yeah i mean that's one thing i suppose
that i've been
quite worried about you know i do
genuinely worry for
the rule of law um quite a lot because
it is sadly under threat and it is i
suppose
we've got four more years over here and
i i really hope
that in the next four weeks uh over
there
you you made the right decision let's
hope so all right uh
peter from leeds uk i appreciate the
call
let me go next to our friend
maddie from evanston illinois maddie uh
what's uh what's going on with you
what's on your mind today and you uh
you are on
maddie you can go ahead i see you've
unmuted but we can't hear you
might be a an issue of microphone
selection
all right maddie just i'll give you one
more opportunity there you are maddie
oh awesome hi david um first of all
thank you so much for all that you do
you're giving me such a reality check
right now and i really appreciate that
good um second of all i you know after
watching last night tonight's debate i
i can't help but wonder how
in the hell the right is like framing
this
and like how they could possibly think
that like
trump might have won the debate like i'm
trying to get into that mindset
i i like simply can't and i'm wondering
if you could like give me any more
insight into that
so basically there's two sets of people
that are defending trump there's people
saying that trump
actually won because biden stuttered
right so there's that group that's
basically just saying that you know
trump just won
there are people and an earlier caller
identified it
um who are conceding or see
implicitly conceding that trump didn't
do so well and he was unhinged in this
stuff
but they're essentially blaming chris
wallace and saying chris wallace was
part of like a fake news media cabal to
give trump the tough questions and to
challenge trump more and that
it was all rigged against donald trump
those are the main two lines of defense
now for me they both ring hollow
but the point is all that really matters
is what the independents thought and and
by maddie
i don't know if you're listening to
something else in the background or that
if that's my own voice feeding back but
maybe we could do something about it
any better now that is better yeah
all right yeah i mean that's crazy but
but
uh helpful to frame it in that way and
um i guess my other question is like
how do i restore my faith
in this democratic process when uh you
know
the leadership is telling me that like
you know if
it goes the way that he doesn't want it
to go then we're all
like screwed and anarchy will rain etc
etc so in the
in the immediate 30 it's horrifying in
the immediate 30 however many days we
have left
in the immediate 30 or however many days
we have left what we have to do
is just overwhelm the vote and try to
get the biggest victory possible
if and when we do that then we can talk
about fixing these other systemic issues
which have been exposed including that
our checks and balances really only work
if somebody enforces them and what we've
learned under donald trump is if nobody
enforces them they don't really do much
for us
yeah all right matty it sounds like
you've got a lot going on there so i'm
gonna let you go but i really appreciate
you talking to me all right thanks so
much
take care all right there's maddie
maddie having a very very busy day there
okay guys uh a success the first day
taking calls on discord the call quality
was stunning
and i really appreciate everybody who
got in touch we will
do it again next week the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week some very good ones first
one is about trump voters hey david
why is it that rural and blue collar as
well as
older white people seem to favor donald
trump so
yes that is true it's important to
remember that
increasingly this group is not leaning
as much towards trump as they as they
once were we looked at numbers in
i believe it was pennsylvania maybe
wisconsin some other places where
the white vote is not as in favor of
donald trump this year
as it was in 2016 but the final numbers
remain to be seen but yes it's true that
donald trump's strongest demographic
group remains uh white folks and older
folks although older folks overall have
abandoned trump and now favor joe biden
but the question is why it's a good one
and understanding the why is necessary
if democrats don't want to make the same
mistakes as
as they did in 2016. now of course 2016
was rife with
you know james comey's press conferences
about hillary clinton's emails
and foreign meddling you know all these
different factors
but there was a bit of a lack of
understanding from
from hillary clinton and democrats about
how to talk about economic anxiety
now there was racism there's this big
debate over anybody saying economic
anxiety
explains trump's win is ignoring racism
no it was both
and for some people it was more one than
more more one or the other
but there's no doubt that over the last
20 30 years of globalization
as we've seen much manufacturing go
elsewhere and the u.s
become more of a service-based economy
the people disproportionately
affected by that are folks working in
manufacturing jobs manufacturing jobs
are disproportionately in more rural
areas and midwestern states and in other
places like that
and those who have benefited from the
united states
moving towards being a service economy
have been people
on the coasts in cities tech workers
service workers and
others so one reality is
that on in total you know there was this
neoliberal idea
that in the aggregate the u.s would do
better
the economy would in total be better
there would be more total wealth and
lower
overall prices with this change of
moving manufacturing out and creating
service and
information jobs that happened but it
was overwhelmingly concentrated
in certain parts of the country and not
in others but
politics aside it was also
overwhelmingly concentrated for the one
percent
as we see stagnant wages for large
swaths of americans
and huge income and wealth gains
for the top one percent and even groups
smaller than the top one percent so
for some people they
fell for trump's rhetoric around trade
and the middle class
it was bs populist rhetoric it went
nowhere
but there was a group already
predisposed to favor republicans
in many parts of the country rural older
white
who fell for it and uh it has not gone
particularly well for them now
separately if you look at evangelical
and religious voters
they also are predisposed to vote on
abortion lines
trump claimed to be anti-abortion in
2016 he still claims to hillary clinton
was
in favor of a woman's right to choose so
for some folks it's not actually about
economics it's as simple as as abortion
which continues to be a not only a
voting issue but
the voting issue for many americans so
there's whenever we want to look into
these questions
this is part of what i spoke about
earlier this week in our interview about
the us possibly as several countries
331 million people most countries don't
have this many people
and you have radically different
uh not just ideologies but concerns and
day-to-day life the day-to-day life of
someone who lives in boston and works at
a tech firm
has almost nothing to do with the life
of someone who is a
you know rural ohio factory worker
we speak the same language we're
americans etcetera but
these are very lit different day-to-day
experience both
culturally and even just in the nuts and
bolts logistics of it
and you can't really give one answer to
any question that asks about
such a broad trend in a country of 330
million people hey david on balance do
you think that the protests
help or hurt donald trump uh i think
that they heard him i
i believe that early the idea that trump
had was that they would help i just
think he miscalculated
there is no question that when you see
protests
some small portion of which end up
having some violent elements and arrests
taking place
arson looting etc um certainly trump's
base is activated
they are motivated they become more
enthusiastic about
voting for donald trump i don't deny
that the problem is
i think that the protests are really
hurting trump with everybody who's not
already committed to him and
if you only are pleasing the people
already voting for you
you can't make up a three five seven or
nine point
popular vote deficit which is what
different polls claim
donald trump is currently experiencing
most people
aren't falling for if you see a violent
confrontation in portland
that's what you will have under joe
biden's america most people aren't
falling for that most people are
accurately recognizing wait a second
biden's america trump's president right
now this
is happening in trump's america right
now and it reminds me a little bit of
the
the situation when donald trump was
asked about
early in coronavirus earlier in corona
virus do you take responsibility for
this or that
and trump said i take no responsibility
at all apply
that logic to the protests
and to the elements of the protests that
have been violent which again is very
very small
and trump actually spotlights those
incidents
thinking it will hurt joe biden and he
says it's biden's fault that this is
happening
it's radical marxist fault that this is
happening and it will be even worse if
they win
it's backfiring because it doesn't pass
the sniff test and what this ultimately
gets back to
is that donald trump was a much stronger
candidate running as an insurgent
who had not had a career in politics and
who could
sort of credibly criticize whoever is
running and whoever is in power
trump's been president now for four
years and yet he's still trying to run
like an insurgent trump is still saying
you've got to re-elect me so i can do
the wall
and do health care and do more taxes and
all of this other stuff
he's been president for four years and
it's a gambit
that i believe has failed him he may
still win for other reasons but i think
continuing to run as an outsider even
though he's been president now for four
years
i think it's a mistake and if you look
at the polling data you see it
when the unrest happened in wisconsin
there were people saying this is going
to hurt joe biden and it's going to hurt
democrats
you had enlightened centrist grifters
right saying trump just won
the senate is going to stay republican
because of what's going on in wisconsin
a lot of pundits jumped all over that
not pundents as some say pundits come on
we know the word p-u-n-d-i-t
and in fact joe biden is polling
slightly better today in wisconsin than
he was
uh when jacob blake got shot it's
marginal it's a small
it's a small delta but things have not
gotten worse for joe biden in wisconsin
since that happened and i think that
what's happening or two different things
one
most people aren't buying that what
we're seeing has anything to do with joe
biden it's happening under donald trump
and trump's actions have actually
worsened it when trump
sent federal agents like jack-booted
thugs
to areas with unrest to carry out you
know authoritarian
soviet-style tactics throwing people
into vans and all of this stuff
he could have instead used the bully
pulpit
to say we are demanding federal
investigations of the police officers
and departments involved
this is not what the next four years are
going to look like
in america he could have listened to
people on systemic race right he could
have done it differently and i think
he'd be cruising to re-election if he
had done that
and paid more attention to the virus for
sure
but instead he didn't do that and uh
it it uh has made it it has fomented
the feeling that things are unstable and
instability tends not to be good for the
incumbent so that's my bottom line i
think that donald trump's base
is certainly enthusiastic going to vote
for trump
because of the protests but they were
going to vote for trump anyway maybe
they're just doing it slightly more
enthusiastically
i think with everybody else the protests
have been very very bad for donald trump
david if joe biden gets elected and
democrats take the senate what will
democrats actually get done
so first of all if biden wins and
democrats take the senate
it's a two-year period okay democrats
could then lose the senate in 2022 or
lose the house we don't know
there's the low-hanging fruit and then
there's the more complicated stuff so
certainly joe biden will have no choice
but to use executive orders to undo a
ton of trump's executive orders now
fortunately many of trump's executive
orders were just symbolic in nature
they didn't really do much but a lot of
executive orders will be needed to stop
the damage of trump's executive orders
that do
things i do think that relatively
quickly
a democratic senate and joe biden would
move to try to undo
as much as possible of donald trump's
tax reform plan
that included handouts to the very rich
and even provisions that allow donald
trump to extend his tax loss carry
forwards indefinitely rather than just
10 or 18 years however much it was
but there's a really big question here
which is that
republicans now i mean listen they
stopped merit garland in 2016
and now they will probably succeed at
putting in amy coney barrett
they don't care about hypocrisy they
will obstruct they will do whatever
democrats if they win the senate and joe
biden wins
are going to have to grapple with what
to do about the filibuster
the filibuster which requires 60 senate
votes instead of a simple majority
to get a lot of things done and i don't
think we are going to see major
legislative action
if republicans really suffer an
embarrassing defeat where trump has made
a one-term president which is rare in
american politics
and if republicans lose the senate
they're going to be hurting and they
will get in the way of anything they can
i don't see obamacare being expanded the
way joe biden wants
without uh 60 votes and there's no way
that they're going to get 60 votes so
the question will be do they get rid of
the filibuster i don't see
joe biden's clean energy plan going
anywhere
if it depends on you know a senate that
is 52 to 48
in favor of democrats if that's what it
is so if democrats
take control of the senate and they
rewrite the filibuster rules
then you may see more action done now
are they going to do that
it's risky barack obama alluded to it at
the funeral of john lewis
that's probably the highest profile
support we've seen of getting rid of the
filibuster but
understand that whatever democrats
imagine that it takes i don't know 8 to
12 months of joe biden's first term
to get rid of the filibuster and then
democrats get something done
in the second year of joe biden's first
term
and then imagine that republicans take
back the senate
and maybe even the house we don't know
in 2022
you have opened the door for republicans
to use the lack of a filibuster
to do ungodly things so this is always
the question is it does it start a race
to the bottom
i don't know the answer but if somehow
democrats figured out a way to get the
votes i believe the priorities would be
deal with coronavirus relief in a more
serious manner if
depending on when that happens expand
obamacare
in the way that joe biden wants to do
new tax reform plan
clean energy those would be the four
that i see the most likely that
democrats would want to tackle
if given the opportunity again depending
on what degree of a majority
do they have in the senate or do they
get rid of the filibuster one last thing
without getting rid of the filibuster
democrats could
still get things done if they take the
senate even if it's only
you know 5149 5248
but they will have to concede a ton to
republicans
they will have to pass their bills
with these horrifying disgusting
amendments
that they put in there in order to get
some republican votes
is the country better off if that's what
they do
i don't know you've really got to look
at the specifics we've got a great bonus
show for you today with producer pat
ford we will be back next week with
the regular show the bonus show and the
vice presidential debate is next week
kamala i think she's going to crush
crush crush mike pence
we'll see you next week if you're not a
member if you are a member
enjoy the bonus show coming up right
after this
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video